la communauté iranienne de toronto
s'organisent pour aider le poète
cinéaste et écrivain mostafa azizi
détenue en iran depuis février dans la
même prison où est morte en 2003 la
faute aux journalistes canado iranienne
zahra kazemi
parmi les amis on est vraiment inquiet
mostafa aziz sy et citoyens iraniens est
résident permanent au canada un acteur
influent de la communauté iranienne de
toronto depuis quatre ans l'iran
l'accusent d'avoir insulté le leader
suprême de l'iran et d'avoir fait de la
propagande contre le régime
il a été arrêté quelques semaines après
son arrivée en iran alors qu'il visitait
son père malade à sa fille n'en revient
pas chaque nom ses amis non plus en tant
que iranien parfois comme tout le monde
il s'exprimait il exprimait ses idées
politiques sur la situation en iran soso
une page de facebook sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis son arrestation sa page
facebook personnelle n'est plus
accessible
seul un compte pour demander sa
libération les maintenant j'espère que
mustapha aziz sy avait confié à son ami
constance plus le risque existait des
libyens mais je pense était risqué l'été
prêteurs à prendre les proches de
mostafa azizi presse maintenant ottawa
d'agir
même si le gouvernement dit avoir peu de
marge de manoeuvre
on nous n'avons présence en iran mais
nous travaillons avec nos alliés surtout
à l'italie katanga la famille craque
mostafa azizi soient emprisonnés
longtemps si rien n'est fait pour
l'aider
mostafa asie doit subir son procès en
juin en iran
mais ses proches sont loin d'être
rassurés ils n'ont pas confiance en la
justice iranienne
ici julian lamoureux radio canada compte